obviously it's gonna be a huge day for
us the huge day is finally here
bachelor nations re lion dyke jr. and
his wife Lauren welcomed their first
child together a baby girl we're excited
to start a family and and we've bought a
beautiful house and we're really
settling in in Arizona
the couple first announced they were
expecting on Instagram in November of
2018 with a series of sonogram snaps the
bachelor alums have shared their
pregnancy journey on social media
they've even created an account for
their daughter I would say it's a little
bit of a vibe yeah ahead of their little
ones birth ari and Lauren jetted off on
a babymoon to Bermuda and dished to et
about the exciting trip we can't wait I
know I think you know we traveled so
much last year and we haven't traveled
since our wedding so this is kind of the
first weekend we've been out of the
house we're really excited she wants
another thing sand beach so we're going
the pair tied the knot in a gorgeous
ceremony in Hawaii in January 2019 girls
dream about getting married in Hawaii
it's a beautiful destination wedding
spot which of course was officiated by
none other than Chris Harrison
they called me what a couple months ago
when they announced they called and they
were both on the phone and they said you
know we would really love it if you
would fly out and officiate the wedding
for so we can't think of anyone better
now I am I really I was touched I'm
honored congratulations to the new
parents
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]